Let me a show you a series of
examples of what it means to
take these now images at different
exposure values, to be able to generate
something equivalent to a stack of
images at different exposure values and
again, here, we're basically giving
it a lot of different samples.
Again, an underexposed dark image,
you can see the outside.
Now, of course,
I've made it a little brighter,
more, more, and
now you can actually see in detail.
This was always visible but now more
of the insides are becoming visible and
as we keep going, you'll notice
that outside gets overexposed and
some of the insides are also
getting a little overexposed and
detail is kind of getting lost.
You're getting a little bit
of a halo effect here and
all that kind of stuff too.
Even more now, actually,
the boundaries are getting lost.
So let's save this as
my stack of images.
What we did in the previous case was we
calibrated but this would, of course,
could be done for a real image.
Again, in this case, what I basically
did was I took different images and
note that in this instance,
I actually have all of these images
aligned because I put them on a tripod.
If they were not on a tripod, what
you would've had to do is, of course,
do image alignment.
Remember the stuff that we looked
at when we talked about panoramas,
as we'd have to align
these images together.